There are two ways of meditating on death.
Uh,
one is the more bid way, uh, which is uh,
a kind of avoidance of life and a sense
that nothing is worthwhile because it's
all gonna come to an end.
And the other is the creative way of
recognizing that that your mortality is a
fundamental part of all that you hope for.
You know,
when we fall in love with another,
when one falls in love
with another person,
one is consciously taking under ones care,
a mortal being and it's the sense
of her fragility in term mortality,
which is fundamental to the so the love
that one feels towards her in my view.
Uh, and uh, if you try and
exclude the thought of death, uh,
then that love is weakened.
The sense that you're,
you have that she is absolutely
dependent on that love.
And of course we'll one day
escape from it in through death.
That is absolutely a part of what the
love is and why we find in erotic lover
kind of redemption.
That's asked what I would say 10
I would say as well that it's an,
it's an aid to concentration and focus.
You don't have much time and there's
plenty of problems and so you and,
and it's going to be a
hard road no matter what.
And so get at it. You know, for years,
when I was in my twenties
the first thought I had when
I woke up in the morning
was life is short.
I really literally,
it happened to me for years and I
thought, no, time to waste. Then there's,
there's, there's things to be done,
there's things that need doing,
get the hell up,
make yourself efficient,
aim at something that makes the
transients of life worthwhile because such
things exist.
And then,
and then do everything you can to manifest
everything you can within that mortal
frame. And, and it,
it adds to life of a seriousness
that would otherwise be absent.
Oh,
I'll tell you my plumber story
because that makes it concrete.
I've done a lot of home renovation.
I've worked with lots of workmen and on
very creative projects as a matter of
fact. And so that was very entertaining
because with carpenters for example,
we built a quite strange and unique
third floor on my house in Toronto and I
invited the carpenters to contribute.
I told them what the overall view was
and what we were trying to produce,
but if they had creative ideas,
then I was welcoming them
because I wanted them to,
I didn't want to tell them what to do.
I wanted to produce something beautiful
with them fully on board so that it was
likely to manifest itself
in the best possible manner.
And so that competence that
that I described rather
rather utilitarian manner is
almost immediately transcended
by something that's more
potent and more valuable
in the actuality of it.
If you're participating in a project
like that and you invite people into a
reciprocal relationship,
then the relationship begins to
transcend the particularities of, of the,
of the project, and then the
project goes wonderfully well. So,
and that is a reflection of
something that's deeper in it.
It touches on something that Sir
Roger mentioned statement by Christ,
that if two or three people are
gathered together in his name,
that he's there and you can,
you can infuse every relationship you
have with precisely that spirit if you're
cognizant of it and careful,
I mean it's and fortunate and,
and far more than that.
It's a thing to strive for and you
won't manifest itself perfectly,
but that can be there and
all the particularities. And
so that way you have the,
the singularity of the project itself,
the practicality of that,
there's a reason that Christ was also a
carpenter, right? That's the particular,
cause a house that's not built on
truth does not stand, you know,
and so those particular relationships
should partake of that divine,
the divinity of ultimate reciprocity.
And then both are,
both are elevated and,
and so,
so it that the narrowness of,
of,
of say capitalists trade is insufficient,
but it's embedded in something that
when it's not a zero sum game, it's,
it's embedded in something that's far
deeper than that and far more gratifying.
And if,
and if you're careful about such things,
then the projects that you
involve yourself with that
or even somewhat mundane
can take on a much more,
much,
much more beautiful and productive,
uh, nature. And then that's,
well, it's not frustrating. It's,
it's, it's compelling and it works. So
yeah, I would just add to that that, um,
what Jordan has said really
is that in a job rightly done,
the divine is imminent in some
way and George Herbert said,
and who sweeps the rumors for they
laws makes that and the action fine.
Um, okay, we leave out these days
that drug makes drudgery divine bit,
but, um, you know, the habit
was absolutely right about that.
That two W if you ask the question,
where does God enter the ordinary life,
it is in that sense of doing something
for its own sake, uh, and uh,
and acquiring the habit of doing so and
not wanting a rewards beyond the thing.
Um,
which is co connects with Aristotle's
conception of what a virtue is as well.
So, um, Eh weren't,
shouldn't despair that there is a
moral education available to us,
even in a world where there
isn't a formalized and,
and shared religion that that will bring
that aspect of things to bear on human
life.
What I,
what I would say is the term happiness
means ultimately the full fee,
your fulfillment as a person, uh, and uh,
that that isn't the same as
gratification of your desires. It is,
it means the kind of
transformation of your, um,
your being such that you can look on
what you are and say for all my faults,
uh, I accept that thing. Uh, and,
and when they're on an
occasion comes to rejoice,
you're accepted and enter it
rather than say, asking yourself,
do I deserve it? You know, those, uh,
that's that avoidance of joy,
which many people have is actually
itself a kind of narcissism.
They're happy person goes
out and embraces the,
the occasion for rejoicing
and he does. So, um,
because uh,
his own nature is at ease with itself
and you can incorporate this into it.
Of course, there's a lot more to
it there. That one has to have,
as Aristotle says,
happiness is an activity of the
soul in accordance with virtue.
What he meant was that, um, that
if you don't have the virtues,
you're trading always on a thin ground
that you all fall through in that
wonderful moment when it at last few
years is going to say yes. You know,
uh, you, you turn out your,
your nature as a Predator
is revealed. Do you use the
Jordan's image? A new full,
uh,
irrecoverably but anyway,
that's brief discourse on happiness.
Well,
I mean for me,
like I find a tremendous,
first of all there's an alliance
between happiness and gratitude.
And you touched on that. If you're going
to accept the tragic reality of life,
let's say,
then it's also reasonable to accept
happiness when it comes your way.
And to be grateful for it
and to be grateful for it
is to accept it and to enjoy
it. Well, it makes its presence felt
it's something that visits I would say.
And you can invite that
visitation. I would say. Um, um,
I do that primarily by playing.
Um,
I was very playful with my
kids and my wife and still am,
I mean most of the time with my kids,
it was nonstop jokes
of one form or another.
My daughter can barely say anything that
isn't a joke of some sort, you know?
And I hang around with comedians all
the time and I usually have my best
discussions with them and my
best friends when I grew up,
especially when I was young,
young man,
where people who were inveterate ironist
and joke tellers and mostly what we did
was competitive humor.
The whole goal of it social gathering
was to see who could say the most
outrageously funny thing.
And that was unbelievably entertaining.
And so if that comes along and you can
participate in it and you can play so
much,
the better.
And so it's even useful to touch things
that are difficult with a playful and
light hand,
which is partly why I traveled with
Dave Ruben in my lecture series because
Dave's a professional stand up comedian
as well as a serious person in his own
right.
But all of the very disturbing
lectures that I put forward,
because I think they are disturbing
our Lavand with, with humor and that,
that there's purpose.
That's, that's purposeful.
It's necessary and
desirable. So, but it's,
but that doesn't mean that I think that
short term happiness is a goal. It's,
which I certainly don't think that it is.